septembre 1932 le ministère de l'air
britannique et mais un appel d'offres
pour la fabrication d'un bombardier
d'urnes expérimental un bimoteur aux
capacités accrues par rapport à celle de
ses prédécesseurs
les constructeurs soumettent plusieurs
modèles potentiel conforme aux demandes
spécifiques du gouvernement rende les
pets je soumets le hp 52 ans ben dunn
vickers répondent à l'appel en proposant
le concept prônée par l'un de ses
éminents ingénieurs barnes waris wallis
était le concepteur de la structure du
dirigeable air 100 pour le compte d'une
filiale de la vigueur
l'aer chip ganassi compagnie
wallis était l'un des pionniers de la
méthode construction dit en nid
d'abeille d'eilat métallique
s'entrecroisant pour former une sorte de
triage une structure qui se révèle des
plus robustes à l'époque où le ministère
de l'air et mais son appel d'offres ou
alice se voit rejoint par un autre
ingénieur de réputation solide rakes
pierson ensemble les deux ingénieurs
produisent le tout premier bombardier à
fuselage en nid d'abeille le vickers où
elle est selon le wells les bombardiers
biplace de moins de trois tonnes et est
un petit appareil est le caractère
novateur de sa structure en nid
d'abeille permet d'envisager la
conception d'appareils plus lourd norman
bauer et elle a des collaborateurs de
barnes ou alès dans la conception du
wedding le fait de travailler avec par
mois lindsay une expérience profondément
formatrice et est d'un caractère
difficile mais il savait pertinemment ce
qu'ils faisaient c'était un ingénieur en
paix à ce moment là on rechercher la
perfection s'il n'était pas ingénieur en
chef
il répondait aux ordres de monsieur
personnes c'était bien la personne à
l'origine de tout ce qui avait trait à
la conception structurelle de là vient
il était impliqué dans la conception
d'aérostats depuis plusieurs années il
savait très bien ce qu'il faisait ses
intérêts recouvrer une quantité de
sujets autres que l'aéronautique
il avait de nombreux passants il
dessinait il était très doué pour le
dessin
on peut dire que c'était outre un
technicien un artiste très complet
afin de répondre au cahier des charges
émis par le ministère vickers propose un
appareil mono plan dans la structure
repose et intégralement sur le concept
en nid d'abeille on l'avait baptisé
modèle 271 le ministère ne cacha pas son
intérêt envers le modèle et commandites
à la fabrication d'un prototype le
fuselage du nouvel appareil été
recouverts de toile l'ensemble devait
comporter un train d'atterrissage
rétractable et être propulsée par les
tout récents moteurs rolls royce gauche
rock à système de refroidissement
liquide
mais à mesure que les travaux avancent
sur le prototype on découvre que les
moteurs n'ont pas la puissance
nécessaire et sont vite remplacés par
des moteurs radio bristol pegasus à
refroidissement par air
le prototype décollent de la base
aérienne de buckland dans son baptême de
l'air en juin 1936 aux commandes se
trouve installé ji sommers pilote
d'essai attitré de la société vickers
peu après le premier vol le modèle
apparaît à la présentation des appareils
de la rfa nda où il attire immédiatement
l'attention à la suite d'une série
d'essais officiels de la ministère de
l'air passe la commande de 180 appareils
identiques avec m
ces appareils devaient être fabriqués
selon une série de critères de
production développées à la suite de
l'analyse du prototype des changements
radicaux devait intervenir dans la
conception du fuselage et la structure
du train d'atterrissage en décembre 1937
après maints perfectionnement le
wellington marque un effectué son vol
inaugural la production enchaîne débute
dans l'usiné vickers à wayne bridge où
l'on s'est fixé comme incroyable défi de
produire un avion par jour mais bientôt
cet objectif est dépassée que par la
nécessité de pourvoir non seulement à la
commande d'origine mais également aux
commandes additionnelles de la part du
ministère de l'air de nouvelles usines
sont construites à chester à blackpool
ses deux nouvelles usines permettent
d'accroître la productivité pour fournir
jusqu'à 180 appareils par mois au plus
fort de la production les trois usines
parviennent à fournir un nombre total de
300 appareils en un seul mois
à mesure que la production se poursuit
d'autres modifications interviennent sur
l'appareil pour en améliorer les
performances et l'efficacité au cours de
la seconde guerre mondiale les variantes
apporté au wellington entraîneront la
multiplication des versions de
l'appareil du mark 1 aux marques 10
les ingénieurs se tourner vers des
moteurs aux performances accrues de 850
à 700 chevaux
et en plus des moteurs bristol pegasus
les ingénieurs choisissent de recourir
au bristol hercules et au merlyn de
rolls royce
ces changements apportés au châssis en
nid d'abeille de l'appareil permettent à
plus ou moins court terme au wellington
d'emporter une charge d'armement
supérieur les wellington employés au
cours de la guerre était deux fois plus
lourd que le prototype d'origine
mais ils pouvaient embarquer plus de
bombes qu'il avait été initialement
prévu le wellington l'emporter dans ses
flancs un équipage de six personnes est
prouvée en pleine charge de carburant
monte jusqu'à quinze mille pieds en
bénéficiant d'une autonomie de 4800 km
chargés de deux tonnes de bombes
l'appareil pouvait même monté jusqu'à
dix-huit mille pieds en complément des
tourelles à double canon actionner
électriquement situé dans le nez et la
queue de l'appareil la première version
du wellington disposait d'un troisième
double canon situé sous le ventre de
l'appareil
l'équipage était constitué d'un pilote
d'un navigateur opérateur radio de deux
canonniers et d'un bombardier rrf
intègre le wellington à l'escadron de
bombardier numéro 99 hamilton rôle en
octobre 1938 à l'éclatement de la guerre
l'année suivante les équipages sont
rodés à l'appareil et la rs dispose de
six escadrille complète prête au combat
en première ligne
lorsque j'ai vu le wheeling tonne pour
la première fois il lui est tout de
suite apparu comme un avion d'avant
guerre
elles avaient été fabriquées avec un
certain accent sur la qualité ne siège
du pilote était un cuir teint envers
magnifique
il n'avait jamais vu de sièges aussi
confortable c'était extraordinaire
c'était un petit objet de luxe auquel je
me suis vite attaché
j'ai volé entre 1200 et 1300 heures
dessus ça crée des liens
c'est un fait reconnu l'avion sur lequel
vous passez le plus grand nombre
d'heures et votre avion préféré 24
heures après le début des hostilités le
wellington par au feu 29 appareils
anglais prennent leur envol avec pour
objectif des navires allemands
15 blenheim de l'escadron numéro 2 se
déploie au dessus de ville est ma femme
pour attaquer le vaisseau allemand
amiral cher au même moment 14 wellington
de l'escadron numéro 3 montrent une
attaque des vaisseaux de guerre chan
lorsque les naseaux le jour de l'entrée
en guerre
le 3 septembre 1939 le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que personne d'entre
nous n'était véritablement entraîner ou
quoi il se trouve que j'avais malgré
tout quelques heures de vol derrière moi
et que je faisais partie d'un équipage
constitué au préalable en tant que
canonniers je pouvais donc servir dans
un rôle mais nous n'étions pas vraiment
prêt après tout c'était le premier jour
de la guerre et on ne connaissait pas
les conditions de combat
ceci nous a pas empêché de faire une
sortie sur les charrs
on l'a atteint de plusieurs coups
d'ailleurs mais pas assez efficace car
il nous a fallu revenir peu de temps
plus tard pour finir ce que nous avions
commencé de wellington les cinq bnm sont
abattus lors de ce premier raid mené au
petit matin mais bien que certaines
bombes et atteint leur cible
la majorité des projectiles explosent à
part cinq jours plus tard le 18 décembre
un groupe de 24 wellington d'école pour
une mission de reconnaissance sans
escorte au dessus de wilaya fun et les
routes autour de chéri
prévenus par leurs observateurs de la
poche des appareils anglais la luftwaffe
se tient prête à les recevoir
les chasseurs allemands intercepte les
appareils anglais et frappe avec force
ils attaquent en surplomb de
l'escadrille de wellington qui se
retrouve impuissant la défense
constituée par leurs canons vente rose
se révélant totalement inutile dix des
appareils sont abattus et des 14 qui
retourne en angleterre trois autres sont
sévèrement atteints c'était une
tentative assez vaine dire les allemands
avaient pu nous voir arriver
il anticipait notre venue et
physiquement ils ont pu nous voir
arriver de loin grâce à une météo
idyllique ce jour la terre et les
messages me contre les wellington
c'est une situation sans issue pour les
bombardiers je crois me souvenir que
plus de la moitié des wellington fut
abattu ce qui finit par convaincre le
ministère de l'air que l'on pouvait pas
se mesurer à armes égales avec le
chasseur mais ils continuèrent quand
même d'essayer
et quand j'ai été libéré de mon camp en
allemagne en 1945
j'ai retrouvé mon capitaine qui était
devenu alors un air marshal carte
et qui m'a dit vous avez nous étions
forts nous envoyer au combat sans
escorte et j'ai répondu que oui à quoi
il a ajouté nous voulions juste vérifier
quelque chose à fabriquer des tourelles
sur la marque 1 à et qui ont rapidement
été remplacé
à l'origine le wind hilton était équipé
de deux tourelles l'une à l'avant et une
à l'arrière équiper toutes deux de
double canon 303 browning et d'une
tourelle sous le ventre de l'appareil
telle était la puissance de feu
d'origine
les chefs d'escadrille se sont rendus
compte de l'inefficacité de ces naturel
ventrale placé sur le margot accepterait
le ventrale manqué d'amplitude et de
rayons quand les donc rendait le travail
du canonnier trop difficile pesée en
outre 750 kg ce qui était une surcharge
pondérale réellement trop importante
ils ont finalement décidé de l'éliminer
à partir de là les idées se sont
multipliés pour compenser la perte de
cette tourelle à l'initiative des
mécaniciens et des ingénieurs sur les
bases elle même on a pensé à fixer un
canon dans un des dom au centre du
fuselage mais l'importance du calibre du
canon n'était pas compatible avec la
configuration un peu spécifique du
fuselage
on s'est alors contenté de placer deux
mitrailleuses sur les flancs de
l'appareil à peu près à la hauteur ou la
tour elle se trouvait sur le modèle
précédent
on a d'abord eu recours à une
mitrailleuse actionnée par un
compresseur la mitrailleuse contenait
deux chargeurs mais là aussi ils
ensemble a été remplacé par des
mitrailleuses
la carrière du wellington connaît un
moment décisif en 1940
en mars de cette année le ministère de
la guerre et met une directive levant
l'interdiction de bombarder des cibles
terrestres le wellington et est
désormais à même d'opérer de nuit
c'était la fonction à laquelle il était
destiné et il allait s'y révéler dans
toute son efficacité
les premières missions nocturnes baptisé
redd smic elle consistait simplement en
des largages au dessus de l'allemagne de
tracts de propagande destinée à la
population pour les équipages
il s'agit en même temps du
perfectionnement de leurs entraînements
en vol nocturne
les raids de bombardement débute au
printemps de l'année 1940 avec l'attak
de base aérienne allemande et
d'entrepôts en hollande et au danemark
en mai le commandement ordonne le
bombardement offensif du territoire
allemand
son bombardier dont 40 wellington
bombardent la zone industrielle de la
ruhr en juin les wellington prennent
part à une attaque des positions
allemandes à dunkerque et à la
déclaration de guerre par l'italie le 10
du même mois il mène une brève campagne
sur des objectifs industriels italiens
vers la fin du mois d'août ou au point
culminant de la bataille d'angleterre la
luftwaffe change de stratégie pour s'en
prendre directement à la ville de
londres
f réplique immédiatement le 25 août 17
wellington s'envole pour bombarder berne
c'est la première attaque de la haye
rêve contre la capitale allemande
au cours de la bataille d'angleterre et
la menace qui planait était que les
allemands parviennent à détruire les
relais radio relais qui subissait le feu
de façon régulière les se quittant les
allemands à l'écart des relais suis tout
simplement le bombardement de londres
c'est un concours de circonstances que
churchill a à la fois vu comme une
tragique mais aussi comme une occasion
rêvée de déployer l'effort maximum en
préparation de l' attaque sur pearl
je suis arrivé sans connaître mon
équipage et quand j'ai posé les yeux sur
eux je les ai trouvés dans un état
lamentable
les avait tous une mine encore plus
terrible que la mienne je leur ai alors
dit veinard vous allez devoir m'emmener
à berlin vous parlez d'une chance ils
étaient jeunes sans expérience
j'ai alors attiré le pilote à l'écart
pour lui demander vous ne trouvez pas
que l'équipage est un peu jeune ce à
quoi il m'a répondu je sais le plus
jeune a 17 ans
j ai alors dit mais cette prise ag oui
j'ai 19 ans et vous avez beaucoup
d'heures de vol
oui 250 sur plusieurs types d'appareils
j'ai eu comme un haut le coeur en
entendant ça alors que j'avais déjà moi
même totalisé plus de 1000 heures de vol
nous sommes donc partis pour berlin et
tout s'est relativement bien passé nous
avons atteint le territoire allemand
il faut quand même garder à l'esprit que
toute l'europe était sous la coupe de
hitler et au milieu de toute cette
étendue
voilà notre petit avions perdu comme une
mouche au milieu de la soupe on a lâché
des bombes éclairantes nous ces gamins
en vo milieu du ciel qui ne savait même
pas où il avait jeté leurs bombes
nous avons touché la ville
mais l'endroit précis nous est restée
inconnue
et puis nous avons fait demi tour pour
rentrer à la base
cinq appareils sont perdues au dessus de
berlin et bien que les dommages subis
par la ville et étaient moindres le coup
porté au moral allemands étaient
considérables outre leur participation
dans les offensives stratégiques les
wellington joue un rôle important dans
de nombreux raids à l'encontre des
forces d'invasion allemande qui se
massent dans les ports de la manche
les bombardiers effectué de jour comme
de nuit 1 à la sable pilonnage des
barges et des vaisseaux
d'approvisionnement au cours du même
mois les wellington de l'escadron 70
sont les premiers appareils de la ras
affecté au combat au moyen-orient par
ailleurs les escadrons 37 et 38 furent
envoyés en egypte pour prêter leur
puissance de feu à la lutte contre les
forces italiennes
l'escadron 70 semaines la première
attaque contre benghazi et en quelques
mois les winches comme on a désormais
pris l'habitude de les surnommer
réussissent à repousser les italiens de
l'autre côté de la frontière égyptienne
ils prennent aussi part à la campagne de
grèce face à l'africa corps de romell à
l'époque de la bataille d'el alamein six
escadrons complet de wellington sont en
activité dans le désert nous étions
basés autour du canal nous rejoignons
régulièrement des bases avancées qui se
trouvait à 800 km à l'ouest de suez par
delà le delta du nil en direction du
désert
ces bases avancées étaient
considérablement ravitailler en bombe et
en carburant c'est là que nous
procédions à notre ravitaillement pour
nous envoler le soir même vers benghazi
où dieu sait où encore
nous prenions donc les airs pour
rejoindre ses bases vers 10 ou 11 heures
du matin dans des appareils bien sûr
n'était pas à l'époque équipés de
climatisations et la chaleur étaient
réellement infernale on ne pouvait poser
la main sur une caisse métallique sans
se brûler
c'est incroyable de voir à quel
variations de température ses avions
étaient soumis à l'époque
le wellington apparaît dans plusieurs
films de propagande allier une
significative d'entre eux étant targets
for tonight ou la cible de ce soir
l'histoire d'un raid au dessus de
l'allemagne comme tant d'autres détails
et depuis l'élaboration du plan d'
attaques jusqu'au débriefing suivant
leur aide
bien qu'il s'agisse d'un escadron fictif
sans volant d'une base tout aussi
fictive
le film était interprété par un
véritable équipage de wellington issues
du sang 49e escadron alors que le
wellington s'illustre dans ses missions
au cours de la seule année 1940 vickers
produit 140 appareils par mois
quand on gagne on est au près de skopje
avec vous
pique nique
un autre film est tourné au profit du
secrétariat d'état à l'information pour
illustrer la nécessité de doubler la
productivité dans workers week-end une
équipe d'ouvriers de l'une des trois
usines nikkei se fixe le défi de
construire un bombardier totalement
opérationnel en moins de 30 heures le
texte lu par un officier de la royal
canadian air force des montres public
l'efficacité de la structure en nid
d'abeille l'opération débute à 9h du
matin et doit durer la majeure partie du
week-end on commence par rapporter deux
pièces du fuselage dans ce hangar
l'objectif premier de ce film est de
montrer le rôle d'une équipe dans la
productivité d'une usine ou et à
l'effort de guerre
mais il s'agit aussi d'un appel à
volontaires soutenir l'effort de guerre
de très nombreuses femmes ils répondront
pour compenser la mobilisation sur le
front de la majorité de la main d'oeuvre
masculine le fuselage est assemblée en
éléments distincts par autant de sous
groupes indépendants travaillant
simultanément on combine ensuite des
éléments réalisés dans des ateliers ou
et à des tâches tout aussi spécifique
quel que soit le stade de l'assemblage
les équipes travaillent dans un seul et
même objectif
après quelques minutes on peut déjà
avoir une idée de la taille kora le
bombardier achevée soit une vingtaine de
mètres de longueur
parmi les ouvrières on trouve des femmes
issus de toutes les catégories sociales
occupants préalable toutes sortes
d'activités
le message est que dans la nécessité la
porte est ouverte à tous et à tous dans
chacun des ateliers des superviseurs
inspectent chaque stade de la
fabrication pour garantir le rendement
sans que l'éventualité d'un défaut à
corriger le retard de les autres phases
dans le cas présent les équipes sont
considérablement avancé dans leurs
tâches une heure seulement après le
début des opérations
en parallèle on assemble les systèmes
opérationnels et l'équipement tel le
radiateur du code pin à l'assemblage
principal on ajuste déjà le plancher en
bois au fuselage chaque élément
s'assemblent à la perfection dénotant la
précision du travail à compter de part
et d'autre malgré la thématique de
vitesse
l'encadrement de la cloison du cockpit
est ajustée suivi de près par le siège
du pilote
le manche à balai et le plancher d'une
seule pièce les équipes oeuvres de plus
une heure et 17 minutes
en remplaçant les hommes absents dans
les usines les femmes n'accomplisse et
pas seulement ceux qu'elles estiment
être leur devoir le film vise à montrer
la parité devant ce travail en
angleterre comme aux états unis
c'était une occasion inespérée de se
réaliser en entrant dans la vie active à
des postes jusque là réservé aux 6 à la
fin de la guerre nombre d'entre ces
femmes rendirent leur place l'effort de
guerre aura ainsi contribué à changer à
jamais le monde du travail
à 10h27 sur l'ordre du contremaître
l'équipe chargée de la mise en place de
toute l'installation électrique
pénètrent dans la carcasse muni de son
outillage face aux impératifs de temps
l'équipe se voit accru de plusieurs
personnes accomplissant un travail
nécessitant de la précision en temps
normal qui se double en l'occurrence
d'une rigoureuse coordination les gestes
se doivent d'être rapide efficace pour
ne rien entravé du processus ici encore
la responsabilité des superviseurs au
sein de cette véritable fourmilière et
de veiller à ce que rien ne soit bâclé
et que rien ne compromettre l'intégrité
de l'appareil
de cette masse grouillante et de cette
confusion sort bientôt le fuselage en
passe d'être achevée à 13h45 le fuselage
est amené depuis l'atelier vers la
section où l'intégralité de la surface
de l'appareil sera recouverte de toile
une fois de plus la tâche accomplie ici
requiert une précision sans faille aux
mouvements de la part de ces couturières
que d'entraîner la casse d'une aiguille
contre l'infrastructure métallique
entraînant plusieurs minutes de retard
la toile est fixé à l'infrastructure par
limite petit boulon les coutures
contribuer à raffermir l'ensemble à
raison de huit points de couture tous
les deux centimètres et demi
l'aspect répétitif de la tâche est
compensé par le nombre d'ouvriers au
travail avec la même minutie longtemps
la toile sur la structure géodésique du
corps de l'avion est la découpe est un
instant crucial mais moindre dérapage
constitue un gaspillage de matières
premières et nécessite plusieurs minutes
de réajustement outre leur participation
aux travaux de couture mais hommes
procède à la phase suivante qui consiste
à être en shérif y est le fuselage par
l'application de la presse l'enduit d'un
lent grisâtre virale ocre rouge qu'on
sait chaque couche sont nécessaires pour
garantir la régularité et l'homogénéité
du revêtement et la rapidité de séchage
fait que l'équipe chargée de cette tâche
ne rencontrera aucun retard tout comme
les pilotes ne peignent leur appareil à
l'éffigie de pin up ou les décors de
motifs empruntés au dessin animé les
ouvriers ne se prive pas de laisser leur
marque sur l'appareil
depuis un autre atelier situé à l'autre
bout du hangar
on amène grâce à une grue un des deux
moteurs bristol pegasus que l'on descend
pour l'ajuster à sa nacelle les comme on
les surnomme également seront ensuite
transmis à la phase suivante
d'assemblage les mécaniciens a signé à
la présente tâche était aussi bien
stewards sur un bateau de ligne que
styliste dans le cas de cette jeune
femme le commentaire insiste à
l'attention du public sur l'égalité des
capacités de chacun quel que soit leur
niveau devant un travail qualifié le
ministère de l'information
espérant ainsi encourager le volontariat
de tous horizons
les éléments achevée au sein des sous
groupes sont acheminés vers une partie
centrale du hangar où ils vont être
combinées l'ensemble va peu à peu
commencé à prendre corps il est 18h15
soit 9h15 après le début de l'opération
les nacelles sont amenés toujours à
lagruère attaché aux ailes tout comme
l'on peut nage dans l'instant qui suit
chaque partie est traitée là aussi par
une équipe distincte de l'autre côté de
l'appareil on s'apprête à installer la
structure métallique destinée à recevoir
des bons dans les ailes on dispose les
réservoirs d'essence bradés après quoi
la grue soulève les ailes et les amène
sur les flancs de l'avion où elles
seront fixés définitivement nous donnant
son envergure de 25 mètres là où le
public est étonné de voir les choses
mener à une telle cadence
les équipes ne font qu'appliquer plus de
vitesse à leurs opérations routinières
alors que l'on amène des lices gauche le
moment est venu pour la relève il n'est
que 20h23 samedi soir les ouvriers ne
manque pas de faire des paris quant à
l'issue du défi fixé
il leur reste dix sept heures et vingt
minutes avant le délai imparti amène la
tourelle arrière et on procède aussitôt
à son assemblage les os de la main
d'oeuvre constitue le résultat d'un long
travail et de la vérification en un mot
on procède à l'installation des deux
roues du train d'atterrissage d'un mètre
quarante de diamètre et pesant 150 kilos
chacune cette tentative de record est un
évènement tel pour les employés de
l'usiné vickers que certains ouvriers
n'hésitent pas à venir contribuer
quelques heures de temps à l'effort
collectif malgré leur peu de
disponibilité
chaque espace est optimisé pour le g le
carburant est peu à peu
l'appareil adopte ses attributs de
bombardier les couleurs et les cocardes
sont appliquées en même temps que se
déroulent les autres opérations
car malgré le caractère exceptionnel que
revêt la conception de l'avion celui ci
sera acheminée vers sa base
d'affectation sitôt achevée on procède à
quelques contrôles sur certaines
portions de l'appareil à l'horloge de
lusine qui les 2h40 du matin un tracteur
amène le bombardier vers la zone la plus
spacieuse du hangar où auront lieu les
ultimes vérifications et les essais
moteurs une certaine fébrilité parcours
tous les gens présents un sentiment
d'attentes rehaussée par la présence de
hauts responsables de l'état major et de
la presse malgré l'échéance de nombreux
techniciens accompagne l'avion encore
unanime et pour mener à bien les tâches
qui leur ont été assignées
chacun son tour a tiré profit de la
moindre minute restant avant le passage
au stade ultime de vérification les
river aux couturières des mécaniciens
ingénieurs chacun des membres de
l'équipe à son niveau attend de voir le
résultat de son travail de plusieurs
heures aux premières lueurs du jour
à 6h15 du matin soit précisément 21h15
après le lancement du chronomètre le
bombardier se présente compléter aux
portes du hangar prêt à sortir
devant les effectif au grand complet
réunis pour assister aux débuts de leur
création les mécaniciens s'installe aux
commandes et procède à l'essai décisif
celui des premiers tours de moteur
davantage de superviseur s'affairent
autour de l'avion sans en oublier un
seul centimètre carré
et bien que le chronomètre tourne un
générateur est une des hélices ont
besoin de subir un dernier réglage et
quelques points de couture sont encore
nécessaires ce qui coûte 2 heures
additionnelles
enfin des moteurs au circuit électrique
en passant par le fuselage chacun des
éléments reçoit le feu vert
l'avion est jugé apte trait au décollage
le jour est à présent bien levé à 20h50
23h50 après les premiers assemblages
l'avion roule sur le tarmac adjacent
rengard de façon indiscutable le record
est bel et bien battu
à cette heure matinale gerald de wind et
le pilote d'essai de vickers qui a
assisté la veille aux travaux et même
tiré du lit pour procéder aux tests en
vol
lui qui s'attendait à des essais une
demi journée plus tard
le ministère de l'information est
satisfait workers week-end parvient à
éveiller les bonnes volontés en
établissant aux yeux du public que grâce
à l'effort de tous il est possible
construire un bombardier en 24 heures et
48 minutes
le même jour à 19h45 le bombardier
s'envole pour sa base d'affectation en
1941 en emploi des wellington à des
missions de largage de mines et d'autres
sont affectés à la défense côtière pour
des missions de torpillage en septembre
1941 wellington aux formes étranges
prend l'air pour la première fois le
marque 5 un appareil expérimental doit
subir des tests en vue de la production
en masse d'appareils de haute altitude à
48 pieds le wellington serait à l'abri
des tirs de décès à et des assauts des
chasseurs ennemis mais bien qu'une
version marque 6 et suivi le marque 5
aucun des deux appareils ne sera à même
d'atteindre les altitudes espérer
incapable de voler à plus de trente
mille pieds les versions deux portes
altitude ne seront jamais utilisés dans
leur fonction première
l'appareil est aussi appliquée à des
missions à l'encontre de sous-marins
ennemis et à la reconnaissance en haute
mer en janvier un cerceau de 14 mètres
de diamètre est adapté au fuselage du
wellington pour contrecarrer la nouvelle
arme des nazis la mine maritime
magnétique
le cerceau et rattaché à un moteur
électrique l'ensemble produisant un
champ électromagnétique
si le wellington vol suffisamment bas le
dispositif est assez puissant pour faire
exploser les mines magnétiques les
wellington marque un équipé ainsi
deviennent connus sous l'immatriculation
des w y qualifier les appareils munis de
dispositifs directionnelle autonome en
1941 ce dispositif se révèle utile dans
le rôle de défense côtière joué par le
wellington dans la lutte anti sous
marins on développe un procédé nommé
l'elite ou éclairage led destinées à
faciliter la localisation nocturne de
sous-marins ennemis
ce puissant faisceau de lumière
permettait de détecter un sous-marin à
près de 2 km un sous-marin pris dans le
faisceau risquer de subir un
bombardement ou un déferlement de charge
de profondeur
après une série d'essais effectués sur
la version marque 1
le procédé reçoit l'approbation de
l'état majeur et l'escadron 172 devient
la première unité de défense côtière
équipé du faisceau de l'oeil leur
premier sous marin est repérée dans la
nuit du 6 juin 1942
devant l'impossibilité de rester
invisible
les sous marins allemands reçoivent pour
consigne de rester continuellement en
plongée jusqu'à ce qu'il soit inévitable
de faire surface les sous-marins
récupère ainsi un peu de leur efficacité
et disparaissent à nouveau des regards
scrutateurs des alliés compliquant la
tâche des wellington
mais le vent tournera une nouvelle fois
lorsque le radar asv équipera les
marques 3d 1943 inspiré de la
configuration du modèle de radar h2s le
nouveau dispositif dote les wellington
de la possibilité d'effectuer des
missions nocturnes de repérage à longue
portée ce radar permet à partir de cette
époque et jusqu'en 1945 de détruire
nombre de sous-marins dans les
wellington se sont chargés d'éliminer 26
d'entre eux en 1941 cet art wellington
modifié qui lâche la première est
désormais légendaire bombe de deux
tonnes lite blockbuster la briseuse de
murailles barnes willis est à l'origine
de la fabrication de la bombe qui est
envoyé pour la première fois dans un
raid sur emden dans la nuit du 1er avril
et la même année le sergent james ward
de la royal air force de nouvelle
zélande est le premier pilote de
wellington à se voir des corps et de la
victoria cross
c'était un charmant garçon qui venait
d'être nommé professeur il était timide
et fut très gêné d'être ainsi honoré
je me souviens qu'une semaine mais tard
je lui ai demandé un autographe
or ma soeur qui les collectionnait et
cela l'avait profondément embarrassé il
était pilote on second sous dawson ça
comme le pilote principal
illfurth attaqué par un chasseur et un
de leurs moteurs le moteur droit était
en feu l'avion perdait de l'altitude
le chasseur avait rompu l'engagement et
le bombardier revenait à travers la mer
du nord mais toujours en flammes à
persuader l'équipage de le laisser
tenter une manoeuvre incroyable il a
fait sauter la verrière du dôme
supérieur il s'est attaché avec une
corde et en perforant la toile et en se
servant de l'infrastructure en nid
d'abeilles comme d'échelon sans
parachute
lorsqu ils n'auraient jamais pu sortir
de son orifice avec un parachute sur le
dos il a rampé jusqu'au moteur sur
lequel il a dirigé l'extincteur mais
sans immédiatement éteindre le feu mais
en tout cas en lots réduisant de façon
importante vers le temps qu'ils
reviennent dans le fuselage
le feu était alors presque éteint
l'avion s'est posé loin de la base mais
ils sont tous rentrés sains et saufs
la vitesse en l'air à ce moment-là
devait être d'environ 90 ne et bien que
le pilote ait baissé le train
d'atterrissage est ouvert les soutes
abondent pour ralentir l'appareil dont
compte
80 et 90 ne s'ils avaient été soufflées
d'elle à cette vitesse là il n'aurait
jamais survécu en 1942 la version marque
3 du wellington est affecté aux escadre
de bombardier plus rapide que les
versions précédentes
le mark iii devient le bombardier
bimoteur attitré de la rfl ce point du
conflit mondial les efforts des
bombardiers ne semble avoir qu'un effet
limité sur l'état des forces ennemies la
r f dont les ressources sont sollicités
simultanément sur plusieurs fronts se
voit contrainte de réduire les effectifs
lors de missions au dessus du territoire
allemand
dispersés sur des zones de plus en plus
vastes les bombardiers paraissent plus
isolé et offre des cibles faciles aux
chasseurs de la luftwaffe
les pertes sont énormes du côté des
bombardiers anglais ceci ne parviennent
pas à causer des dommages équivalent aux
allemands mais se vend deux défaites
doit bientôt tourner en février 1942 un
nouveau commandant en chef des forces de
frappes aériennes est nommé en la
personne de air marshal arthur harris
bombers à risque comme il devient
rapidement connu est un ardent défenseur
d'une stratégie d' attaque massive
prenant des frappes menées par de tels
effectifs que l'ennemi dépassé en serait
rendue complètement impuissant harris
croyait aussi fermement que des frappes
au dessus des objectifs civils en plein
coeur de grandes villes contribuerait à
miner le moral du peuple allemand
afin de démontrer l'efficacité de cette
stratégie des plantes sont immédiatement
dressé réquisitionnant des effectifs
jamais mobilisé jusqu alors pour
atteindre une cible unique harris avait
pour idée de réunir 1000 bombardier
battant ainsi le rappel du moindre
appareil disponible le plan demande des
semaines de préparation mais la nuit du
30 mai 1940 2046 bombardier prennent
leur envol en direction de la ville de
cologne
bien que cet type d'appareil furent
utilisés les wellington compté pour plus
de la moitié des effectifs de cette
flotte 599 wellington ainsi que des
lancaster halifax sterlings manchester
hamdane et des wheat les attaques la
ville par surprise en trois vagues
successives durant 90 minutes les avions
ont largué un nombre impressionnant de
bombes incendiaires ou explosives
douglas l'eau était pilote de l'un des
premiers wellington a survolé cologne
lorsque les reds furent autorisées la
façon de grossir les effectifs udall et
engager les unités encore en formation
nous étions donc mobilisés dès le stade
de l'entraînement l'un des détails les
plus frappants était que les appareils
avait une autonomie assez poussées que
les moteurs n'avaient pour leur part pas
assez d'huile pour tenir la distance
il y avait donc un réservoir d'huile
auxiliaires dans le fuselage
la tâche de l'un des membres d'équipage
étaient alors de pomper l'huile afin
d'alimenter les moteurs y avait une
pompe que l'on activé à la main dans
l'appareil et je vous dispense raid
était taillé de chansons de corps de
garde que cela nous inspirait les tirs
anti-aériens et les balles traçantes
faisait partie alors de notre quotidien
ce qui nous inspire est le plus de
craintes étaient les chasseurs de tubes
envoyé en formation ouvert votre
objectif vous aviez un cap que vous
gardiez jusqu'au dernier moment pour
tromper au maximum la vigilance de ceux
qui vous attendent et au dernier moment
vous verriez pour reprendre le cap sur
l'objectif réel est là sans croiser y
ait un ou plusieurs chasseurs c'était
fini nous avons été attaqués comme ça
six ou sept fois avec pour seule défense
le canonnier à l'arrière avec ses deux
mitrailleuses bonne le seul espoir
d'échapper un chasseur était de faire
des acrobaties en l'air pour l'empêcher
de tirer au but
c'était une manoeuvre assez désespéré
parce que certains de ces chasseurs vous
trouvez avec une forme un peu primitif
de radars mais ils avaient donc déjà un
certain avantage tandis que chez nous le
canonnier ils n'avaient pour instrument
de viser que ses deux yeux
ils voyaient déjà à peine à travers une
verrière salle et de plus il n'avait pas
du tout un point de vue optimale on a
corrigé d'ailleurs la configuration de
la que sur les modèles suivants pour
remédier à ce problème
plus de 10000 incendies sont déclenchés
et une fois leurs raids effectués à
mesure que les avions reprennent la
direction de leurs bases les lueur des
feux sont encore visibles à 180 km
cologne est dévasté certaines zones
rayés de la carte en particulier les
complexes industriels intégralement
annulé près de 500 civils périssent dans
l' attaque et 5000 sont blessés les
pertes au sein de la flotte sont
moindres 48 appareils sur 1000 ne
rentrons pas au bercail en juin 48
heures après le raid de cologne les
wellington constituent le gros d'une
nouvelle flotte qui prend cette fois
pour objectif la ville de l'essonne et
un troisième raid le 25 juin vise la
ville de brême le coup porté au moral de
la population allemande fait de ces
opérations successives un succès sans
précédent
de façon encore plus significative d'un
point de vue stratégique les bombardiers
se montre à part entière comme un
instrument de frappe vital dans la
résolution rapide du conflit
à partir du mois de juillet on donne
tous les moyens nécessaires à
l'optimisation des capacités de la
flotte de bombardier ces moyens
permettent la mise en place d'une
planification exhaustive d'une campagne
de bombardements en travaillant sur le
long terme
la rs redoublent simultanément deux
missions de largage de tracts au-dessus
de l'allemagne visant à provoquer la
population locale et à accentuer le coup
préalablement forte au moral par les
frappes armer les tracts présente une
mise en garde sur les hostilités encore
à venir accompagnés d'un message des
plus provocateurs de la part de winston
churchill
avec le temps les villes ports et
complexe militaro industriel allemand
connaîtront un harcèlement quand jamais
vu sur une durée une intensité sévérité
systématique encore jamais avérée
en août des wellington des 109 et 156e
escadron se joignait la toute nouvelle
forces aéroportées baptisé path finder
placés sous les ordres du capitaine john
bennet équipé d'instruments de
navigation à la pointe de la technique
cette force d'élite est constitué pour
affiner encore l'efficacité et la
précision des bombardements
volant en avant-garde de la faute de
bombardier les appareils du groupe
fender se chargent de marquer la cible
en l'éclairant grâce à des fusées et des
balises
outre son rôle opérationnel le
wellington est alors appliqué aux essais
du nouveau radar dgi et du tout nouveau
système au bo le premier raid escorté
par les pattes fender a lieu le 18 août
et avant la fin de l'année 1942 la
stratégie a intégralement fait ses
preuves en 1943 l'angleterre produit un
nombre chaque jour exponentielle de
bombardier disponible en grand nombre et
doté d'une capacité de charge accrue les
halifax et lancaster prennent peu à peu
l'avantagé sur les wellington au sein de
la flotte de bombardier 9 escadron
anciennement d'équipé de wellington ce
docte des plus récents couacs du moteur
entre janvier et octobre 1943 12
escadron additionnel de wellington
opèrent leur conversion vers d'autres
types d'appareils cinq escadrons
adoptent des lancaster et 5 optent pour
le halifax et les deux escadrons restant
penche pour les stars
bien que les wellington et continue à
servir d'appareil d'entraînement ils
sont démobilisés du groupe a après un
dernier raid le 8 octobre 1943 menée par
les escadrons 300 et 400 32 au dessus de
la ville de hanovre
denjean peine
toile
et g
mais les wellington reste néanmoins en
service aux alliés traversant la manche
et progressant à travers l'europe un
soutien tactique effectuant des missions
de reconnaissance sous la bannière de la
2e escadre tactique les wellington
restent opérationnels au combat dans le
moyen orient jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
en italie le wellington sert de
bombardier de première ligne jusqu'en
mars 1945 le jour de l'armistice les
wellington effectué une ultime mission
anti sous marins
bien que nombre d'entre les wellington
sont reconvertis en avion école ils
connaissent un rapide déclin et ce dès
la fin des hostilités le dernier
wellington à être construits sortira des
usines de blackpool en octobre 1945